alright folks we have our first trailer
for venom or Eddie Brock it doesn't show
much and if I do a trailer review or
conventional trailer video that I
usually do I won't be able to add
anything people haven't already said so
I wanted to do something a little
different cuz I was scrolling through
the comment sections of this video of
this trailer there's a bunch of 116
comments cuz that 116 Tom Hardy does
this we should do you see the symbiote
crawling up his neck which is pretty
sweet because I'm scrolling through I'm
saying [ __ ] like 116 when you don't see
venom in the venom trailer which is the
reaction of some people I've gotta look
at it let me just take a couple minutes
and rattle those off because they
cracked me up when Bitcoin wouldn't
Bitcoin hit 6k I knew a few people
myself included that was the reaction
fact when it hit 8 I was like and hit 6
I was dead but I felt like when I saw
Cloverfield paradox
I get it 116 when my alarm goes off as
an on morning person I completely
understand this one's simple effective
and true when you step on a lego when
you realize Baz baby is now an Academy
Award nominated film and I will even add
instead of Lego Batman when you touch
wet food while washing the dishes no
[ __ ] shame I hate doing the dishes i
procrastinate on that [ __ ] like a mother
[ __ ] or when I do dishes shits funky
it's just like that you're like wash and
bleep oh yeah
when you realize you left your phone on
the bus I was at Comic Con with a friend
we both went to an after-party we got
super trash came back to the hotel he
realized he left his phone on the bus
his reaction was pretty much dude
where's my phone
it's real when your little brother
breaks your favorite video game but if I
broke chrono trigger my bra I don't
think my brother would have reacted that
way he would have been really calm and I
would have disappeared how it feels to
chew five
other thing that's gonna be in the
marketing campaign totally [ __ ] bit when
you nut and she keeps on sucking I saw
one of those that was a home alone to
give but it was Marv getting shocked he
turns into his skeleton when he taketh
big crap alright that's simple but
effective I'll give it to you as someone
who operates on the internet with his
YouTube channel I get this one when the
Wi-Fi goes down shoe that phone data oh
here we go
when you forgot to save your game
nothing worse wait to real person who
commented that my reaction after
watching the last Jedi Jedi shade though
gonna be real for quite some time and
we'll do one more and here it when DC
first saw Marvel released the infinity
war trailer
perpetuating the Marvel vs. DC divide
here in my job I don't mean to but it
was pretty funny anyhow those 116
comments they started cracking me up I'm
just scrolling through I was dying so
everyday why not bring you guys in on
the joke that'd be fun a bit different
not a review not even tales from the
comments section so if you think you can
do better hit up that trailer give your
own 1/16 comments there so mall how it's
done my subscribers do it I guess I'm
Michael Jackson and as this is a little
unconventional or out of the ordinary
for my channel if you could share it
spread it around spread the word to
really appreciate it and help me out and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]